اهلا بكم ضربه جديده ان طلقتها جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في مصر بعد اعتقال مسؤول
مكتبها الاداري الدكتور محمد عبد الرحمن
عدد من قادتها في عمليه دهم بمنطقه
القاهره الجديده فيما يتساءل كثيرون عن
اسباب تكاتم السلطات الرسميه على عمليه
الاعتقال بل ونفيها من قبل بعض المصادر
الامنيه يتوقع اخرون ان يكون الهدف من
ورائها تقويض مبادرات الحوار والمصالحه
التي طرحتها اكثر من جهه لا سما ان
الاعتقالات استهدفت هذه المره ما يوصف
بالتيار المعتدل في
الجماعه
يتميز الرجل بالمنهج في تفكيره وفي تقديم
اطروحاته ولهذا لم يكن غريبا ان يتولى
محمد عبد الرحمن المرسي استاذ طب القلب
مسؤوليه المكتب الاداري للاخوان في ظل
ازمه الجماعه حاليا وما يميزه اكثر انه
كان من المتمسكين بمبدا السلميه وعدم
اللجوء للعنف ما دامت هناك خيارات اخرى
وبهذا عرف بانه من حمائم الاخوان وهو ما
دفع البعض قول ان ذلك ربما كان سببا في
انه لم يقتل ولم يعتقل مثل كثير من قاده
الاخوان طيله ما يقارب اربع سنوات لكن ها
هو يعتقل مع عدد اخر من القاده ملامح عده
وتساؤلات يطرحها مراقبون عن عمليه
الاعتقال وسياقها التاريخي اولها انها
اعلنت من جانب الاخوان فقط بينما لم يصدر
اي بيان رسمي عن السلطه ويفسر مراقبون ذلك
بان الشرطه لم تعلن الاعتقال حتى تحصل على
معلومات اضافيه من المعتقلين الجدد وان
جماعه الاخوان اعلنت الاعتقال حتى ياخذ
باقي اعضائها حذرهم لكن متابعين لبيانات
الاخوان يرون انها اكثر من مجرد تحذير
فالبيان الذي اصدره محمود عزت النائب
الاول المختفي للمرشد العام للاخوان لم
يقتصر على استنكار عمليه الاعتقال بل تضمن
ايضا نفيا لاشاعه اعتقاله شخصيا فضلا عن
اعلان ترتيبات تنظيميه برئاسته وتوجيهات
جديده تحدد اسماء الشخصيات المسؤوله عن
تسيير شؤون الجماعه ويكشف بيان عزه امرا
جديدا يتمثل في ان الجماعه صارت تنتهج
فيما يبدو استراتيجيه جديده لا تعتمد على
الاشخاص بل على خلايا او جماعات اصغر
منفصله تدير كل منها المنطقه المسؤوله
عنها وربما يعزز هذه الفكره ما ذكره عزت
في بيانه من ان عبد الرحمن كان مكلفا
باعاده بناء تنظيم الاخوان ويتساءل
مراقبون عن السر وراء اعتقال قيادات
الاخوان الذين ينسبون الى ما يعرف بالتيار
المعتدل في الجماعه والذي يتبنى السلميه
للا العنف وهو ما يفتح الباب في رايهم
للتساؤل عن هدف النظام من اعتقال
المعتدلين ودعاه الحل السياسي في ظل وجود
دعوات للحوار والمصالحه كان ذلك التيار
دعا اليها اضافه الى انها تاتي في ظل
دعوات اخرى للوفاق الوطني في مواجهه
الانقلاب وهو ما يطرح تساؤلات حول موقف
القوى المدنيه من اعتقال قيادات كانت تسعى
للتنسيق معها ومشاركتها الحرك الثوري وفي
الوقت الذي اتسمت فيه بيانات الاخوان بنوع
من القوه فان البعض يتساءل عن تاثير هذه
الاعتقالات على جماعه الاخوان وهل يمكن ان
تقوي موقف التيار الداعي الى استخدام
العنف على حساب تيار الاعتدال وبذلك تزيد
من الانقسام الداخلي في صفوف الجماعه ومدى
تاثير كل تلك التداعيات على دعوات
المصالحه وتوحيد الصف
الثوري لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
اسطنبول الدكتور طلعه فهمي المتحدث
الاعلامي باسم جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
وعبر سكايب من القاهره المحامي والباحث
السياسي اسعد هيكل من برلين الدكتور احمد
بدوي الباحث في قسم العلوم السياسيه بال
جامعه الحره اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا مع
الدكتور طلع فهمي لاساله عن الموقف الان
داخل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بعد
الاعتقالات
الاخيره بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الموقف في
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لا يختلف عن سابقه
فنحن اعتدنا على كل هذه الضربات ويتحملها
جسد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين الضاربه
بجذورها في جغرافيا و تاريخ مصر العريق
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ليست جماعه فرد
ليست جماعه قائد وانما هي جماعه لها قياده
ولها منهج ولها صف ونحن قد اتقنا هذا
الطريق ونحن قد تمرس فيه ونحن نقول ان
اعتقال الدكتور محمد عبد الرحمن ليس لانه
رئيس اللجنه الاداريه العليا لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين فقط وانما هو مسؤول هو
ورفاقه كذلك عن القلب النابض للثوره
المصريه في عامها الرابع بعد الانقلاب وهم
الذين يرفضون كل دعوات المصالحه المهينه
التي يعني تريد الانبطاح والتي تريد
الاستسلام خلافا لما جاء في التقرير ان
هذا التيار كان يدعو لمصالحه او يروج لها
وكل من يراجع بيانات الدكتور محمد عبد
الرحمن المرسي وكل من يراجع بيانات
الدكتور محمود عزت يجد ان هذه الفكره فكره
المصالحه فكره دخيله على ادبيات جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في هذه المرحله وان
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اذا كان قد تم
القبض على مسؤولها الدكتور محمد عبد
الرحمن رئيس اللجنه الاداريه في هذه
المرحله فسوف تنتقل هذه الرايه من بطل الى
بطل ومن قائد الى قائد ومن رجل الى رجال
لان رجال الاخوان المسلمين لا يفرطون ولا
يساومون ولا يداهن ولا يتركون ال دكتور
حملوها باي حال من الاحوال مساله اعتقال
الدكتور محمد عبد الرحمن وقيادات اخرى في
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اعلنتها جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين فقط انقل التساؤل هنا
الى السيد اسعد هيئ هيكل لماذا برايك
مازالت السلطات الرسميه المصريه متكتمه
على مساله اعتقال الدكتور محمد عبد الرم
الرحمن وقياديين اخرين في الجماعه بل ان
هناك مصادر امنيه نفت اصلا فكره او نبا
الاعتقال يعني هو راصد لهذه العمليه يرى
بوضوح ان البيان الذي صدر الذي اكد عمليه
القبض صدر عن جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ونشر
عبر موقعها الرسمي على الفيسبوك وعبر
الانترنت بينما التزمت السلطات المصريه
الصمت اتجاه ذلك قد يبدو الامر يرجع الى
نواحي امنيه تراعيها السلطات المصريه ولا
استطيع انا ايضا ان اؤكد او انفي هذه
الواقعه
لكن حينما نتحدث في ضوء البيان المعلم من
جماعه الاخوان قد تكون السلطات المصريه
لجات الى نوع من السريه حتى تحصل على مزيد
من المعلومات بعد واقعه القبض في المقابل
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اعلنت لانها تبدي
تخوفا في ضوء ما حدث في عمليات القب
السابقه
من مقتل بعض اعضائها وبالتالي الاعلان هنا
جاء من جانب جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لكن
انا لا استطيع ان افسر موقف وزاره
الداخليه المصريه من هذا الامر لكن
العمليه كلها تاتي يعني نحن ننظر اليها
حتى في ضوء ما قال به الاستاذ طلعت الان
هم يقولون انهم صامدون وان هذا ياتي في
اطار النضال والثوره المصريه وهم منها
براء هذه لعبه قديمه ادركنا وفهمناها
وعيناها جيدا النظر الى تاريخ جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين مع اين ربما لمرفه او
قراءه الهدف من وراء هذه الاعتقالات نسال
الدكتور احمد بدوي من برلين
ان كان استهداف هذه المره بهذه الاعتقالات
من يحسبون على ما يوصف بالتيار المعتدل
داخل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ان كان هناك
اي رساله من النظام المصري في اتجاه خصومه
في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين طبعا الرساله واضحه جدا لو بصينا
على ميزان القوه ما بين النظام وجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين بنلاقي ان النظام في
ايده كل الاوراق بالذات بعد فوز ترامب
برئاسه برئاسه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الاخوان المسلمين ما فيش في ايديهم ورق
قوتهم التفاوضيه ضعيفه جدا طبعا عندهم
الشرعيه وعندهم الايمان بقضيتهم كل دي
حاجات طبعا مهمه جدا لكن على ارض الواقع
كمحلل سياسي ما فيش في ايديهم قوه تفاوضيه
النظام بياكد ان اوراق اللعبه في ايده
وبياك ان اي كلام عن المصالحه كلام مش
حقيقي ومش هيحصل النظام ما عندوش اي مصلحه
ما عندوش اي حافز انه هو يتم عمليه مصالحه
حاليا لا مصالحه مع الاخوان ولا الكلام
اللي بيتردد عن ان يبتدي يعمل على اعاده
الوفاق الوطني اقصى ما يمكن ان يعني يطمح
فيه الاخوان حاليا ان يكون في تفاهمات ما
بينهم وبين النظام بمقتضاها يسمح النظام
وده شيء النظام بالفعل ابتدى يعمله من
شهور انه يسمح
لقواعد الاخوان ان هم يعني ينتظموا من
خلال الاسر على المستوى المحلي يعني
يتقابلوا و كان ذلك ممكن ام لا نسال
الدكتور طلعت فهمي من اسطنبول يتحدث ضيفنا
اذا من برلين دكتور طلعت عما يسميه ب
تفاهمات او ما يمكن ان يكون تفاهمات بين
الجماعه وبين النظام المصري حاليا هل هو
مطروح الان بعد هذه الاعتقالات المستمره
والتصفيه المستمره والاحكام بالاعدام في
حق قيادات في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ايه سيدتي يعني من يطرح قولا
عليه ان يدلل عليه وان يبرهن عليه قل
هاتوا برهانكم ان كنتم صادقين جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين لا تطمح الى تفهما مع
هذا النظام جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لا
تسعى الى خروج عشرات او مئات من افرادها
كي يلتقوا في اسر هم يلتقون وفي كل مكان
للاخوان المسلمين في مصر صغ ام كبر مجلس
منتخب وقياده منتخبه ومسؤول منتخب وهذا هو
احد الاسباب الرئيسيه لاعتقال الدكتور
محمد عبد الرحمن ورفاقه انا اقول ان قضيه
الانقلاب ليست قضيه مع الاخوان المسلمين
هي قضيه مع شعب مصر هي قضيه الانقلاب الذي
ازاح رئيسا منتخبا من في انتخابات شارك
فيها 30 مليون مصري قضيه انقلاب انقلب على
برلمان فيه 27 مليون مصري انتخبوه قضيه
انقلاب القلاب مر عليه الان اكثر من ثلاثه
اعوام دكتور طلعت نس ضيفنا حتى نكون
متوازنين في هذا النقاش نسال ضيفنا
الاستاذ اسعد هيكل لماذا يصر النظام على
المواجهه مع خصومه في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين
والاستفزاز بدل الجلوس معهم في الحوار هل
اثبتت المواجهه جدواها حتى
الان لا انا قلت ان هذه لعبه سميتها
باللعبه التاريخيه القديمه التي ادركنا
وعيناها وارد على الاستاذ طلعت الذي يقول
هاتوا برهانكم اقول له ارجع الى التاريخ
تجد تحالف جمال عبد الناصر مع الاخوان
لاقصاء محمد نجيب والقضاء على الاحزاب
المدنيه ارجع الى امر السلات عام 1971
حينما تصالحت معه على حساب القوى اليساريه
ارجع الى عهد مبارك حينما تحالفت في
انتخابات 2010 رغم مقاطعه القوى المدنيه
لهذه الانتخابات في شبه مسرحيه انتخابات
مجلس النواب هذه ثلاث مراحل تاريخيه
وبالتالي حينما يحدث الان عمليات كر وفر
او عمليات قبض يقوم بها النظام مع جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين لا استطيع ان اقطع
بالتاكيد ان هذا ياتي في رفض عمليات
المصالحه ومن الصعب التاكيد على هذا الامر
لكن بالتاكيد استطيع ان اؤكد انه في اقرب
فرصه
ينتهز تحين لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
سينتهوا الامر وسيجلس بالتاكيد على ماده
النظام اما من يتحدث عن الثوره وما الى
ذلك هذه الثوره العظيمه ثوره 25 ي مجدها
التصحيح
انتم الذين اضريت بهذه الثوره وعليكم ان
تتحدثوا في هذه الثوره وعلم ان تتصالحوا
مع الشعب قبل ان تتصلح مع النظام دكتور
احمد بدوي اذا المواقف واضحه سمعنا
المتحدث الاعلامي باسم جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين يقول لا تفاهمات لا مصالحه هي
افكار دخيله جماعه الاخوان اذا الى اين ما
الخيارات المطروحه
والممكن لا المواقف مش واضحه يعني من من
محبسه
جهاد حداد لسه كاتب مقاله في النيويورك
تايمز وواضح فيها ان هو بيفضل ان يكون في
حوار سياسي الصراع ما بين الاخوان والنظام
لازم انه ينتقل من ساحه استخدام القوه انه
يبقى صراع سياسي فالمواقف مش واضحه طبعا
مع احترامي الدكتور طالعه فهمي هو بيعبر
عن وجهه نظر رسميه للاخوان لكن تصريحات
كثيره من محمود عزت من جهاد الحداد زي ما
شفنا في صحيفه النيويورك تايمز
من ابراهيم منير في رغبه الاخوان الاخوان
الجناح الموجود بره مصر يؤمن بالحوار يؤمن
بالسلميه وما فيش اي داعي ان احنا
يعني نزيد من حده الخطاب لان ده مش في
مصلحه اي حد وبالتاكيد مش في مصلحه
الاخوان واحب اثمن الكلام اللي قاله
الزميل من القاهره تاريخ الاخوان تاريخ
فيه قدر كبير جدا من البراجماتيه الاخوان
منظمه سياسيه مش بس منظمه دين
كل ما يبقى اسرع ان هم يحاولوا يتعلموا من
تاريخهم بطريقه اوضح وبطريقه فيها شفافيه
وصراحه اكتر هيكون في مصلحتهم وفي مصلحه
مصر وفي مصلحه القواعد الاخوانيه اللي
بتدفع تثمن الاخطاء الاستراتيجيه اللي
ارتكبها قادتهم شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور
احمد بدوي الباحث في قسم العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الحره الشكر موصول للسيد اسعد
هيكل وهو والمحامي والباحث السياسي كان
معنا عبر سكايب من القاهره ونشكر ايضا من
اسطنبول الدكتور طلع فهمي المتحدث
الاعلامي باسم جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا وشكرا لكم على
المتابعه مشاهدينا بهذا نصل الى نهايه
الحصد الى
اللقاء
ه